first of all how are you doing today
i'm doing all right i'm um on the other
side of the world for you i'm down in
new zealand
it's tomorrow and i can tell you the
future's bright
i've been very lucky to have been to new
zealand a few times
uh all for work and i absolutely love it
there
that country is amazing and what people
don't realize
is how good the dairy products are
that's very true the cheese
oh man we drove i guess maybe
two hours outside of auckland just to go
to a dairy to have their cheese and it
was well worth the trip
and the ice cream there is outrageous
yeah there's a place called duck island
and unfortunately my son who's he's four
um knows exactly where it is on the
street so every time we're walking past
the driving past daddy
daddy daddy daddy duck island
they learn at a young age what sugar
really is yeah
it's great um all right so i'm totally
gonna uh
let's jump into some other things but i
totally want to talk to you about why
you're in new zealand but that's
for later in the conversation um uh
do you think that you tweet too much do
i tweet too much
yeah i'm being sarcastic i know you will
tweet like once a year
i mean i i it uh yeah i'm i'm learning
how kind of powerful twitter is
and frankly it just scares me my wife is
much better at it than i am and she's
got more experience doing it
um but no i i rarely tweet it's usually
if i do it's to support somebody else
i don't i struggle with self-promotion
uh i understand you're not you're not
alone in this uh what
tv series would you love to guest star
on
[Music]
i really loved the blacklist
sure james spader is great i got to do
one of them jessica jones was always
kind of a dream for me to kind of be
be part of that marvel universe and uh
kristen ritter is
uh remarkable and incredibly kind and
generous as a person and i i mean i got
to do it i think
sorry no i i i actually really
enjoyed jessica jones and i believe you
were on season three yeah i think
yeah what might surprise fans of that
series to learn
about the making of that show um how
collaborative it is and how
it felt like being on an indie film set
you know it you assume because it's
marvel there
there's this huge overseeing
puppeteer's hand and it's really not
everybody is allowed to collaborate i
mean kristen even
directed an episode and um
any idea is going to be heard it may be
a bad idea and you don't do it
but um it really felt like
a real collaboration between creative
people
that all love the same thing you have
done a lot of theater work
i am curious which theater
has been your favorite place that you've
performed in
and which theater is your favorite to
watch something in
[Music]
um i got to do hair in the hollywood
bowl
that was bucket list level of
um there was a moment i'm i think i was
running around in tennis shoes and a
loincloth
singing and uh you're looking out at
this
vast field of people in this iconic los
angeles
spot that was pretty remarkable um
i really like watching theater
there's a theater in london called the
almeida
in islington and london and they do some
really
smart and provocative work it's where um
american psycho the musical began um
and uh it's i think it's like 300 400
seats and it's just
intimate well laid out and
you are just immersed in the story and i
really like going there
i could be wrong about this but i read
that you
were going to play a beast
in x-men first class but ended up not
doing it to do a play
or a musical am i wrong about this is
this completely off
no i it's more complicated than that but
it
kind of boiled down to we um
i'd started this musical about andrew
jackson
and we had done it in a small theater
and then a little big theater a little
bit bigger and then we did it in la and
it took almost four or five years to
build it and we were actually
going to be able to take it to broadway
and um
[Music]
that it just seemed a real shame to not
do that
um they were all my friends and people i
collaborated with
for a long period of time and
that's what i really kind of had to do
was it on you to decide what you wanted
to do
um that's a long time ago i would love
to say i chose my art
um but it was more complicated than that
i'll leave it be um jumping into why i
actually get to talk to you today
i'm a big liam neeson fan and i love
watching him punch people in the face
i just do and and i'm not alone he's
all of his action movies he punches
people in the face and fans love it
why do people love watching him kick ass
is there something about liam yes there
is and
i learned it working with him on this
it's that
you can a lot of movies have action in
them
but what was the most interesting part
about doing action
with him was that he approached it
as an opportunity for storytelling
why is he punching this way
in this moment in this story um it's not
as if the narrative
of a thriller stops action happens
and then the narrative picks up we have
to learn something about who's throwing
the punch
who's getting punched and he really
kind of ingrained that in me that these
are opportunities for storytelling what
is it about them that makes them fight
this way
i listen uh getting to work with liam
neeson getting to be in a movie with
lawrence fishburne
uh this is very cool so i am curious how
much did you pay to be in the movie
i know i think um if it weren't so damn
cold
i would have done it for free right i
did hear that it was
a cold shoot oh it was
ridiculous but because we were actually
driving
uh semis on frozen lakes i appreciated
that it was called
yeah liam told me that he actually
jumped in the water
there was a few things where he went in
the water to like do his thing and then
he got you know warmed up and i'm like
i didn't say it to him when i'm like
you're kind of you're you're an older
gentleman
i'm like you you have some balls like i
don't know why are you doing that
i'm like i couldn't believe it were you
there when he was doing that or you just
heard about it
oh no i was standing right next to him
going no
not for me thank you very much because
they give you a safety briefing and the
water's so cold
the the biggest problem you're going to
have is initially you get in the water
and you
you can't breathe it's so cold your
lungs shut down you have to kind of
calm yourself down and get yourself
acclimated to the water
but um that day i think it was -38
and he brought up a really good point is
that once he'd been in the water for a
bit
um we're all standing in the freezing
wind and sleet and snow and he said
actually it's a little bit warmer in the
water because
you know it's not frozen that's actually
something i didn't think about but yet
it's probably yeah like 60 degrees
warmer
the joke's on us we should have been in
the water we would have been fine
until you get out of the water and then
you're regretting life
i love learning about behind the scenes
of the making of a movie
so what might surprise people to learn
about the making
of um the ice road well there's a lot of
good cg out there now
um and there's a little bit in our movie
but
a lot of it was practical we were
actually on trucks
on frozen lakes we were running and
fighting
on frozen lakes um
and that lends itself to to this expanse
of the movie
um you really feel like nature
is a character in the film uh it
actually looks it when you're when
you're watching
the movie yeah you know it it also i
didn't know anything about the ice road
uh prior to watching this movie and i'm
like oh this is actually a very
dangerous thing especially with global
warming
yeah people do this yeah like i'm like i
don't know if i could do this because
that i mean you're literally taking your
life in your hands yeah the
our safety briefing was if the truck
starts to go in
open the window really
yeah because if you get submerged with
the window shut
then the pressure of the water inhibits
your ability to open the door and get
out so you'd just be sucked down with
the truck so they gave us these like
glass breakers and
if you couldn't get it open in time
that's an intense shoot
it was don't don't get me wrong our
safety team was incredible there was
never a point where i
felt uh fear for my life maybe the tips
of my nose and
fingertips because it was cold but um
[Music]
but yeah it was that's one of the joys
of the job as you get to
experience extremes and different
environments and different
uh ways of life uh before i run out of
time with you
uh obviously like every as you can tell
by the things behind
me i'm interested in certain things uh
obviously you are
uh part of the huge amazon series lord
of the rings
um uh what was it like did you go after
that role did they ask you
how did it come happen for you well
um it was a long audition process
and then i kind of didn't
hear from them for a few months i mean
the the whole world
was struggling to figure out what we
were going to do next at that point
and then one of the show runners
jd um called me
and he pitched the part and and pitched
the commitment which is
large and um i could hear on the phone
that there was a pa system and a lot of
noise in the background
and uh i still wasn't sure and i said jd
where
where are you he said i'm in the
hospital i said are you okay he said no
my wife's having a baby
and he's calling me to
pitch a job to me and
um while he's having a kid and i just
thought well
he's got the level of commitment you're
going to need to get this show to be
where it should be
it would be a huge mistake to not take
part
i am so looking forward to this series
and everyone has heard
that amazon is investing a ton of money
to make this the best it could possibly
be
um as someone who is obviously working
on it on the inside does it feel that
way as you're filming that you guys are
making something
huge yeah i mean there is a lot of talk
about the money but i
i kind of feel like that's what you need
to do it right
um it's like if you you found someone
you're in love with you want to buy them
a ring you're going to
do the best you can to show that you're
committed to it
and um it's not unlike that
that this is not a legendarium that you
want to skimp on
oh no 100 also the the world is going to
tune in for this thing
this is like a i mean this is something
that a lot of people
um well anyway enough about that i know
i don't want to get you in any trouble
but
what can you actually say about your
character in the series or are you sort
of on
like full lockdown with that kind of
information
the green light on my zoom call just
started to throb
they're listening um
i i really can't say a lot
and and here's the thing it's usually
annoying
when they tell you not to talk about it
you know
here's what you can't say here's what
you can't say and um
on this one i kind of agree with them
they're
because there's so much attention and
because so much
happens um it's important that we do
protect it so i really can't say a lot
other than you will be glad
you knew so little when you see it yeah
i actually am one of those people that i
don't want to know spoilers
before i see it i want to be surprised
every week
i'm completely on board with the with
that
but at the same time for you as an as an
actor look
i know i love new zealand and i would
love to spend time down there
is it was it a little bit um you know
because
again i don't know if you you might last
a season you might last all five seasons
i i don't know what your thing is
but is it weird to sign on to something
that could be
um multiple years
yes that is weird um
but again with tolkien i mean i was a
huge fan as a kid and
and um as and still am as an adult
and uh it was kind of one of those where
if you say no you might regret it for
the rest of your life it comes out and
you go i could have been doing that
right no no completely um well i will
say uh because i'm just about out of
time
are you are you done soon are you
leaving like uh is this one it's going
to be something that
you are there for like uh you know for
the rest of the year
like how how does it work in terms of
what you get to do with other projects
oh you're asking all the right questions
none of which i have answers to
it it is a bit uh nebulous at this point
um uh we've been here a long time
and they'll let us go when they're done
with us
it's kind of like that well i heard you
guys are filming two seasons like the
first 20 episodes or something
uh which is um it's a lot you know more
than i do
that that's i'm pretty confident um
listen i gotta stop there
and i'm just gonna say uh sincerely i
wish you
nothing but the best and i'm super happy
for you that you get to be part of lord
of the rings because
i'm sure it's going to be awesome enjoy
new zealand and have some ice cream
that i can't have yeah duck island
yeah for real i'll remember that hey
have a great day man thank you
thank you i'll see you again